people killed in Janine by a rare
Israeli air strike they died in the
attack on a mosque in the occupied West
Bank the Israeli Army says it targeted
what it called an underground terrorist
route let's go live now to H Abdul
hammed who's live for us in rala and H
tell us more about what happened
here well the the the the raid happened
in the jine refugee camp and the focus
of that raid was a mosque there where
Israel claimed that there were some uh
gunman from different Palestinian
factions who are preparing and I quote
an imminent attack we don't know exactly
what what's the nature of this attack
now it it happened through an air raid
air raid are are quite rare in in the
occupied West Bank even though in Janine
uh in that same refugee camp there was
some Air Raids uh in July uh presumably
by drones or helicopter gunships now
some reports in the Israeli media are
saying that this time it there were
actually jet fighters in the sky over
that camp and that maybe that was that's
how the strike was carried we haven't
got a confirmation from the military uh
but certainly it gives you an indication
that Israel is going deep into the West
Bank with all its means uh and it says
that it's actually going after uh Hamas
members and support
uh even though there's also some people
who just got detained for voicing
support for Gaza so so the bottom line
is that the Crackdown is
intensifying the Crackdown is absolutely
intensifying I mean just an hour ago we
received some video of that of an
incident that happened next to hebon elu
outside of the alaro refugee camp there
and you can see it clearly on the video
a man walking alone in an empty Street
and he is shot dead from afar by the
soldiers now we're told by witnesses
there uh that this man was actually
driving a car with Israeli license
plates he was trying to find a way back
uh and a way out of that area but
because of the road closures that makes
the freedom of movement so difficult for
Palestinians he sort of got lost and was
trying to ask about what which was the
best route out
um the video really shows him standing
there alone with no one inside posing no
threat being gunned down and then the
ambulance not allowed to reach that uh
him while he's lying on the floor this
is the kind of fear Palestinians across
the occupied West Bank live with 24
hours a day whether whether you such
things could happen at checkpoints uh
like this young man just on a street
with nothing happening or whether in the
middle of the night they're going to be
woken up by loud explosions or by
soldiers in their own homes uh that are
going after people it's that has been
ongoing forever it had been intensified
since the beginning of the year and then
it intensified further uh since the
beginning of this war all right to leave
it there for the moment thanks very much
ABD Hamed ramala